[Applause]
as israelis and palestinians descended
into deadly violence once again
there's been a spate of anti-semitism in
europe
incitements to rape jewish women blared
from cars
in london
racist chance at pro-palestinian rallies
in
germany and a far right-wing crowd
giving the fascist salute in italy
israel turkish president recep tayyip
erdogan
was condemned by the u.s state
department last week
after first criticizing israeli
government actions
then saying this is in their nature they
are only satisfied by
sucking blood we feel like noemi madder
is the president of the jewish union of
students in france
and told us legitimate criticism of
israel whether or not you agree with it
is sometimes used as a cover for
anti-semitism
there is something happening in israel
it's arrived in france and jews
are the first victim of that
france is home to the biggest jewish
population in europe
in recent years they've seen several
deadly attacks and the desecration of a
jewish cemetery with
nazi swastikas jewish people make up
about
one percent of france's population but
according to the latest government
numbers they're the victims of more than
40 percent of racist acts in this
country
we call it the the book of life tom
cohen is an american rabbi from portland
oregon
who's lived in paris for more than 20
years he says many synagogues in france
have special security measures
one of the things that we have to think
about is having uh
bulletproof windows placed in having
man-trap doors
for the entrance and so forth you have
to
to think about am i becoming a target or
not
but he told us he's also experienced
anti-semitism in america
where he says the authorities track it
much less thoroughly
we have some dramatic events here
but i don't think we're i think it's um
being a bit blind to think it's
only here in france there is a law
against anti-semitism
there isn't one in the united states
a deadly dispute in the middle east has
fanned the flames of
centuries-old prejudices in the west for
cbs this morning
holly williams paris
you